bonjour à thomas la conférence annuelle
vient se finir viens de le dire
quels sont les thèmes qui ont été
évoqués lors de l'allocution de sergueï
lavrov et bien comme attendu beaucoup de
sujets abordés lors de cette conférence
de presse très riche très dense qui aura
duré 1h45 et au cours de laquelle
sergueï lavrov a abordé énormément de
sujets de dossiers internationaux
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères qui a d'abord tenu un
discours préliminaire dans lequel il l'a
expliqué s'est exprimé ses inquiétudes
sur ce monde en fièvre
il a très rapidement accusé notamment
les états unis 2 je cite démolir l'
architecture du droit international il
s'est appuyé pour cela sur quelques
exemples à savoir le traité est fait ni
les agissements de l'otan ou encore les
sanctions prises par les états unis à
l'encontre de différents pays et puis
seriez lavrov a passé en revue les
améliorations des liens diplomatiques de
la russie avec certains pays comme la
chine par exemple ou encore l'ukraine
évidemment et même à l'afrique où on
sait les rapprochements ont été nombreux
que l'an passé
et puis sergueï lavrov a abordé le sujet
épineux de la syrie je vous propose
d'écouter ce bilan tiré par le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères concernant
la syrie parmi nos priorités c'est la
lutte contre le terrorisme y compris en
syrie
la poursuite du processus politique dans
ce pays pour les intérêts du peuple
syrien
parmi les résultats de l'année dernière
c'est le lancement du processus
constitutionnel en syrie et le
rétablissement post conflits de ce pays
la réintégration de ce pays dans la
famille arabe
nous avons contribué au règlement des
conflits en libye au yémen en une
une démarche importante pourrait être
l'initiative heureuse de la sécurité
collective dans la région du golfe
persique non l'avoir proposé au sein
d'une colloque qui a réuni les
représentants des pays de la région
et puis sergueï lavrov a répondu aux
très nombreuses questions des
journalistes environ une vingtaine de
questions posées par des journalistes
issus des quatre coins du monde alors on
ne va évidemment pas énumérer ici toutes
les réponses 1 du ministre russe des
affaires étrangères mais on va essayer
de dessiner les points importants une
des questions qui lui étaient posées
concernaient notamment sa relation la
relation à de moscou avec pékin et le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
expliqué que les deux pays avaient une
approche identique sur un certain nombre
de sujets internationaux pour ne pas
dire la quasi totalité un des dossiers
internationaux il a été également
interrogé par un journaliste italien sur
la situation en libye et il a expliqué
sergueï lavrov a expliqué que là
l'erreur principale concernant la libye
a été et bien les agissements de l'otan
l'offensive en 2011 et que depuis eh
bien l'état libyen a été presque
complètement détruit et puis notre
collègue de rt international a interrogé
sergueï lavrov sur la situation dans un
certain nombre de pays qui sont gagnés
par l'instabilité une instabilité
parfois appuyées par des puissances
étrangères on pense évidemment au
venezuela il a demandé donc que notre
confrère de rtl internationale au
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
ce qu'il pouvait prédire des agissements
notamment des états unis sur l'année à
venir évidemment sergueï lavrov a
répondu qu'il était très difficile de
prédire avec précision à ce qui pouvait
se passer mais qu'en tout cas l'occident
fresnes selon lui l'établissement de
nouvelles grandes puissances mondiales
enfin évidemment astorga la voir faire
parler de l'iran ces dossiers brûlants
du moment il a été interrogé à
nombreuses reprises sur la situation
dans le pays il a notamment évoqué
l'attitude des pays européens qui sont
vous avez entre les deux entre les états
unis qui se sont retirés du ji cypihot
hey quelle a été l'attitude des états
unis
des pays européens ces dernières
semaines je propose d'écouter sergueï
lavrov les américains ont posé un
ultimatum à ce trophée européen en
menaçant des taxes des droits de douane
de 25% pour les voitures pour notamment
l'automobile les produits de ces trois
pays
si ces pays ne veulent garder le
mécanisme boris johnson l'a dit tout à
fait ouvertement oublions cet accord
obama réalisons un nouvel accord selon
tran pas les méthodes qu'utilisent nos
partenaires américains sont multiples
sont très variées je ne sais pas prévoir
ce qui ce qui va se passer mais nous
continuons le dialogue avec les
américains et les européens sur tous les
problèmes en animaux évidemment pour
vous dire que sergueï lavrov a été
interrogé sur son avenir au sein du
gouvernement russe
il a simplement expliqué qu'il était
pour le moment comme tous les autres
ministres du gouvernement il assurait
l'intérim de sa fonction voilà pour les
réponses de sergey lavrov lors de cette
conférence de presse ici à moscou
thomas merci pour toutes ces précisions
je rappelle que vous êtes